[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
julien bayou bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nos secrétaire
nationale d'europe écologie les verts on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenter ce
matin par julien lécuyer de la voix du
nord bonjour julien bonjour et julien
bayou le président qui doit s'exprimer
dimanche à 20h est ce que pour vous
c'est une bonne chose qu'ils ne prennent
la parole à ce moment-là et qu'est ce
que vous attendez de son allocution
alors et c'est une bonne chose
évidemment et qu'est-ce que j'en attends
en vrai je suis très embêté pour vous
répondre parce que il avait eu un
discours très fort en avril en disant
que plus rien ne sera comme avant que la
santé l'environnement
compte tenu de la crise sanitaire qui
est en fait une crise écologique
plus rien ne sera comme avant et et
c'est bien là seraient soumis ne serait
sorti du tout-marché disait que c'était
une folie que de les soumettre au tout
marché et depuis la réalité c'est que
plan de sauvegarde après plan de relance
il ya aucune contre partie
environnementale et même en fait aucune
contrepartie sociale et c'est à dire que
vos impôts mes impôts financent et bien
des vols polluants entre paris et
bordeaux comme avant et finance des
fermetures de sites pour renault on va
revenir comme avant et si on met ces
lettres exactement 2 minutes et l'autre
point sur lequel je l'attends c est bien
sur la reconnaissance d'un problème d'un
racisme dans la police et le fait qu'il
va y avoir des sanctions des formations
et la fin de ces contrôles au faciès de
ces discriminations persistantes que le
défenseur des droits a qualifié de
systémiques dans certains endroits
alors il est vrai que emmanuel macron
l'attend beaucoup sur cette question il
a quand même fait connaître un peu son
message il a dit ne faut céder ni aux
amalgames réducteur ni à une protection
coupable vous attendez un message
beaucoup plus radical sur le sur le
sujet de sa part emmanuel macron c'était
en même temps et là c'est le ni-ni tard
que si vous faites nissan y ça vous fait
quoi
moi j'attends effectivement une parole
très forte pour dire que ça n'est pas
normal dans une société qui revendique
la fraternité l'égalité que l'on puisse
savoir 20 % de chance vingt fois plus de
chance ou de malchance d'être contrôlé
par la police si vous êtes noir ou arabe
ou perçu comme tel et que donc on soit
lucide vis-à-vis du racisme qui traverse
toutes nos sociétés il s'agit pas de
dire que la police fait exception il ya
un certain nombre de policiers de
policières qui sont racistes et ce sont
des individus il ya bien sûr les parents
il ya bien sûr des cas individuels et
après il ya la question du commandement
et il faut se demander si parce que
quand vous êtes policier policière vous
faites beaucoup de contrôles à un moment
vous devez rendre des comptes et donc il
ya bien des des chaînes de commandes et
le défenseur des droits je pense à cette
enquête à récente cibler un commissariat
du 12ème arrondissement à paris
c'est là que vous avez pu faire une
enquête avec des discrimination
systémique et donc des questions de
chaîne de commandement mais qu'est-ce
que vous serez sur deux sera ce sera six
années j'aimerais insister sur ce le
fait que ce racisme il n'est pas que
dans la police où il y des policiers et
des policières
c'est dans le logement c'est dans
l'emploi et ça n'est pas nouveau on ne
le découvre pas vous dîtes vous dites
que la france a des relents racistes
c'est le deuxième effet les efforts la
france est raciste pour vous je vous
parle la france d'une partie de la
france d'une partie de la parole raciste
qui s'exprime toujours plus librement
alors que c'est pas une opinion on sait
bien que c'est un délit et donc ne pas
ouvrir les yeux par rapport à ça je
trouve que de la part d'un président de
la république c'est une faute
donc j'attends un regard lucide et non
pas un ni nanani nanana parce qu'avec ça
on n'avance pas et on n'avance pas sur
ce sujet du racisme
depuis des années et des années on peut
juste ça veut dire sur la question très
simplement de la police stop aux
contrôles au faciès donc une traçabilité
des contrôles de police c'est la demande
du défenseur des droits
la fin des techniques d'intervention de
type plaquage ventrale qui a pu conduire
à des drames encore récemment et
certainement pas les remplacer par des
pistolets électriques à impulsion
électrique comme le taser
je fais partie d'une association il
il ya quinze ans déjà reda réseau
d'alerté et d'intervention pour les
droits de l'homme qui avait milité pour
interdire le taser parce que déjà à
l'époque l'onu disait que ça pouvait
générer des violences des bavures dans
le monde et ça s'est illustré
malheureusement de multiples fois donc
c'est pas pour remplacer une clé
d'étranglement par ce qu'il faut dix une
violence l'électrique
est-ce qu'il faut dissoudre une
inspection générale de la police
nationale je crois qu'il faut assumer de
dire que les policiers peuvent pas être
les contrôleurs des policiers donc il
faut dissoudre le talent a remanié et
engager un débat
c'est une demande de l'association des
chrétiens contre l'abolition pour
l'abolition de la torture acat engager
un véritable débat sur la manière dont
on doit contrôler l'action de la police
je pense qu'il faut une bien sûr il faut
une instance indépendante
on peut on peut imaginer que l'agencé
dans son royaume il y eu royaume-uni à
une inspection qui est complètement
indépendante qui dispose de son propre
budget c'est ça que vous voulez je pense
que ces institutions indépendantes
telles que celles du défenseur des
droits ont fait leur preuve et donc
pourquoi pas par exemple la l'a confié
au défenseur des droits est une piste
je pense que le débat doit s'engager
mais en tout cas encore une fois l'enjeu
c'est d'être lucide il y à une
proportion importante de notre
population qui est victime de racisme et
ne pas le reconnaître c'est évidemment
pas prendre le chemin de commencer à
résoudre le problème on ne parle
beaucoup
à l'heure actuelle du privilège blanc
est ce que vous vous pensez qu'il ya en
france un privilège blanc je comprends
que le terme puisse choquer mais en fait
c'est un pour moi c'est un terme
pédagogiques c'est-à-dire que quand vous
vous êtes blanc et que le matin vous ne
pensez pas que en allant en manifestant
en allant manifester vous risquez plus
de contrôles que une personne noire ou
arabe ou perçus comme tels le matin en
vous lavant vous ne pensez pas que vous
aurez des difficultés particulières sur
votre aspect pour demander un logement
par exemple ou faire un entretien
d'embauché
et bien il ya une sorte de privilège est
en tout cas vous êtes moins en
difficulté qu'une personne qui a les
mêmes compétences les mêmes revenus les
mêmes garanties que vous quand il s'agit
par exemple de
postuler pour un logement et donc c'est
une manière pédagogique d'engager le
débat en disant qu'il ya des personnes
qui ont les mêmes compétences mais qui
en plus de difficultés parce que c'est
dans la situation pour les joueurs pas
stigmatisant ce que ce n'est pas
communautariste on sert un
communautariste je pense que ça c'est d
épouvantail agité
encore une fois l'enjeu c'est d'aborder
la question avec sincérité et lucidité
la sincérité c'est de dire notre pays
liberté égalité fraternité ne remplit
pas sa promesse mais c'est pas pour
l'écarter
c'est au contraire pour l'atteindre et
la lucidité c'est de dire écoutez quand
il ya plus de contrôles policiers
quand il ya une discrimination à l
embauche qui est manifeste manifeste
évidente quand il ya des discriminations
à l'accès au logement qui sont évidentes
est ce qu'on se voit les yeux ou est ce
qu'on regarde la réalité en face et
qu'on avis vous vous étiez à la
manifestation sur le sujet des violences
policières à paris mardi soir en
compagnie de parlementaires est ce que
pour vous c'est la place d'élus de la
nation d'être à des manifestations
interdites mais la place des élus de la
nation c'est d'être là où la société
villa où la société demande que la
devise liberté égalité fraternité
s'applique donc évidemment que nous
défendons non seulement bien sûr la
liberté de manifester mais que nous
demandons des réactions des
mobilisations des actions et qu'on
attend que du ministre de l'intérieur
qui soit pas dans les phrases
alambiquées est ce que vous avez entendu
cette phrase qui dit en cas de soupçons
avérés
la suspension sera systématiquement
envisagée on se moque du monde
donc moi je regrette qu'il faille des
manifestations en réalité pour obtenir
le minimum c'est à dire que la
république agissent pour l'égalité parce
que c'est bien ça que nous demandons
mais puisqu'il en faut passer par des
manifestations bien sûr que monsieur
pendant les manifestations et nous
serons dans la rue à l'appel du comité
de soutien à damas au comité des parts
dans le soutien à la famille d'adama
traoré samedi également
allez on va parler de l'écologie puisque
après la crise sanitaire les français le
gouvernement se prépare à affronter la
crise économique et pour la ministre de
la transition écologique
elisabeth bornes l'écologie doit être
une priorité du plan de relance on va
les embêter
la transition écologique dans cette
sortie crise c'est la meilleure
stratégie à la fois pour protéger les
français
d'autres crises les crises climatiques
décret écologique et c'est aussi une
façon de créer de l'emploi
je pense qu'il faut avoir en tête quand
après la crise de 2008 on avait loupé le
redémarrage en a sans doute pris dix ans
de retard
à l'époque mais aujourd'hui on a des
technologies qui sont matures et des
entreprises beaucoup de secteurs
économiques qui sont engagés dans la
transition écologique
s'ils ont changé de cap alors là on
perdrait tout le monde
au contraire il faut accélérer pour
créer de l'emploi ferait la lisent avec
born qui était notre invité le 29 mai
dernier ça va dans le bon sens si on
écoute la ministre pour vous non mais le
problème soupire migrants le master que
dans ce gouvernement munis de la
transition écolo c'est presque un emploi
fictif
il ya des milliards d'euros qui sont
déversées sur la table cette pour la ja
7 pour l'automobile 5 pour l'aérien
encore 15 le 18 pour pardon et
maintenant pour l'aéronautique sans
aucune contrepartie et tenez encore une
fois ni environnementale me sociale et
entendrez les abbés de bornes dire dire
qu'en 2008 on a raté mais quand c'est
tout simple on va faire exactement
pareil quoi qu'elle en dise on est en
train de faire exactement pareil mais
vous comme edith kah pas de contrepartie
présents bruno le maire de molières
france de réduire de 50% ses émissions
de co2 sur les vols intérieurs dix sites
de 1280 à l'eau pour vous c'est pas une
bonne qu'on avait ce que ça a été écrit
dans la loi tout le tout le fait de
demander les chartes tout ça évidemment
ça fait 30 ans qu'on le fait est-ce que
c'est écrit dans la loi
est ce qu'en contrepartie sonnante et
trébuchante d'un prêt c'est-à-dire de la
solidarité nationale de vos impôts de
mes impôts et d'un prêt qui peut très
bien de finir en subventions c'est à
dire en dont on sait très bien et comme
ça a été le cas dans le passé et ce qui
a écrit noir sur blanc ont réduit les
vols intérieurs
paris bordeaux caen géré démarre
aujourd'hui et qui concurrence le train
si le thé la sncf est en déficit
si les trains sont aussi chers
aujourd'hui pour les les ménages qui
veulent partir en vacances c'est aussi
parce que on organise la concurrence
du train par l'avion en subventionnant
ses vols et et ça compte ça conduit bien
sûr à plus de bruit pour les riverains à
plus de pollution et encore une fois il
ya aucune contrepartie sociale
moi j'aurais aimé par exemple qu'on ait
une réflexion à quoi sert la compagnie
up quand on discute avec les syndicats
avec philippe martinez ils vous disent
ça sert à faire du dumping social
on a sorti les agents d'air france dont
les amis dans une nouvelle compagnie
pour les payer moins cher donc on est
perdant sur le plan environnemental et
on est perdant sur le plan social une
véritable contrepartie sociale et
environnementale à ce prêt à air france
et vous réintégrer les agents d'europe
avec l'ancienneté au sein d'air france
vous limitez et vous les redéployer sur
d autres activités et vous limiter les
vols intérieurs paris bordeaux paris
marseille qui n'ont aucun sens ce qui
cause du bruit
d'ailleurs on pourrait tout à fait
envisager des couvre feux beaucoup plus
strictes pour protéger offrir des
soirées tranquilles aux riverains des
couloirs aériens
voilà une manière de réfléchir un monde
d'après qui tire les leçons de la crise
quand j'entends elisabeth blonde encore
rien de savoir ce que vous voulez
réduire les vols intérieurs voulait
réduire forcément le nombre de vols les
agents de l'eop fait des vols intérieurs
est-ce que vouloir réintégrer les agents
moment où si vous voulez les réduire va
forcément y avoir des suppressions
d'emplois et c'est pour ça qu'on parle
plan de transformation et non pas juste
de plans de relance en fait il faut
envisager de il faut sauver des salariés
pas forcément les industries voyez il
faut envisager transformer la manière
dont on envisage notre activité vous
aviez juste avant moi la question d'un
sénateur qui expliquait qu'on avait
laissé fermer des usines de masques de
luxe fer et autres l'enjeu c'est pas de
redémarrer exactement comme avant
l'enjeu c'est de prendre la mesure de
cette crise qui n'est pas qu'une crise
sanitaire qui proviennent crise
écologique qui a été aggravée par la
mondialisation
sa propagation a été aggravée par la par
la mondialisation et les différentes
politiques osterrieth air ou de
délocalisation faibli notre réponse a
trop dit de porter ce discours par
exemple à toulouse où vous êtes vous
êtes en bonne tant en bonne place aux
municipales est-ce que c'est toulon tout
l'emploi tout tissu économique la bac et
ans qui est en jeu
et donc dire on va réduire le trafic
aérien s'est porté un coup à airbus et
donc les gens qui travaillent là bas
peuvent légitimement se poser des
questions sur votre politique mais
personne n'a dit qu'il fallait en finir
avec le ou qu'il ne fallait pas soutenir
l'armée simplement on doit quand même
anticipé le monde du monde qui vient
c'est à dire que quand vous avez la
belgique les pays-bas qui réclame une
taxe sur le kérosène quand dans la
population à monter l'idée que exempter
les avions de et les compagnies
aériennes de taxe sur le kérosène
alors qu'on taxe et le diesel il y avait
une profonde injustice il faut
l'entendre c'est quelque chose qui va
bouger
on ne peut pas continuer à développer
des vols dans tous les sens et donc bien
sûr qu'il faut réduire drastiquement ses
vols intérieurs ça ne m'est pas la
menace immédiate sur sur airbus qu'il
faut accompagner vers une transition
faire d'autre part les duchesses n'y a
pas de contrepartie mais quand bruno le
maire fixe l'objectif d'une économie
décarbonée quand le président de la
république vient dans l'est dans les
bois de france pour miser sur le
véhicule du futur auprès de renault un
véhicule à hydrogène pareil par exemple
est-ce que c'est pas finalement dans le
sens du d'un mouvement de transition
écologique
moi j'ai vu le président de la
république pour soutenir l'agriculture
se rendre sur dans une serre d'automates
chauffer de manière complète et
complètement artificielle ça n'avait
rien à voir avec l'agriculture
biologique et là c'est la même chose
pour vous c'est qu'on va c'est à
comparer mais on mise sur le vix les
discours sur les discours sont vers les
déplacements sont verts mais les anglais
green washing bel et bien sûr si ça
n'est pas dans la loi si ça n'est pas
dans les contreparties si ça n'est pas
écrit noir sur blanc vous on peut tout
lui raconter ce qu'on veut et d'ailleurs
la vérité c'est que renault va fermer
une usine laquelle celle de
choisy-le-roi choisy le roi c'est quoi
la particularité de choisy le roi c'est
la seule qui soit aussi la plus en
pointe en tout cas qui sont engagés dans
l'économie circulaire et le fait de
réparer les moteurs ça veut dire que
plutôt que le le schéma traditionnel jeu
produit c'est utilisé on jette et bien
on promet en offre un service de
réparation
c'est ça qu'il faudrait développer c'est
la seule usine qui va fermer vos impôts
mes impôts
on financer la suppression d'emplois on
parle d'une machine mais ce que quand
même la convention citoyenne pour le
climat doit rendre ses conclusions
bientôt on parle peut-être d'un
référendum sur certaines propositions
est ce que ça allait pas dans le bon
sens finalement cette convention mais
moi j'attends des actes ce qui a fuité
de la convention citoyenne pour le
climat nous adhérons quand on parle de
20 millions de logements rénovés
voilà du concret c'est voilà une
première dans voilà de la création
politique de confier cette mission à
cette échelle oui mais l'enjeu c'est
quel acte parce que des beaux discours
sur l'écologie
j'en ai entendu en 2002 à johannesburg
de la part de jacques chirac
j'en ai entendu en 2007 de la part de
nicolas sarkozy j'en ai entendu de très
très beaux en 2012 de la part de
françois hollande est bien sûr de très
beaux en 2016 2017 de la part du
candidat puis président macron ça fait
18 ans les rapports du giec se succèdent
la biodiversité s'effondre tout le monde
a pu le constater dans sa chair à
travers les canicules et autres les feux
en incendie les parents les feux en
australie avait généré une émotion
mondiale les faits en amazonie également
et là on nous dit que peut-être un jour
on va peut-être agir donc 20 millions de
logements rénovés
c'est oui faisons le ça c'était pour le
coup un plan de relance qui permet de
réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre qui va soulager le porte-monnaie
de deux millions de personnes qui ont du
mal à se chauffer et puis créer des
emplois locaux
c'est d'ailleurs ce que propose bruno
bernard pour la métropole de lyon voilà
du concret et ben justement va parler
des municipales
les conditions sont elles réunies pour
vous pour le second tour le 28 juin le
conseil scientifique a donné hier un
premier feu vert est ce que finalement
le gouvernement eut raison proposé cette
date on s'oriente en tout cas vers un
vote le 28 juin et j'espère que les
françaises et les français pourront être
rassurés sur le fait qu' aller voter et
ne présente aucun risque
pas plus qu'en tout cas aller en
terrasse et que donc oui on peut d
confiner la démocratie et tenir ce
second tour
c'est important je parlais de l'absence
d'engagements concrets au niveau
national sur sur l'écologie sur la
justice sociale avec les élections
municipales il ya une occasion de
d'activer des leviers locaux très très
concret quand on réduit la place de la
voiture en ville on réduit la pollution
quand on développe le vélo en développe
bien sûr des des emplois locaux pareil
avec la rénovation thermique
ce sont des moyens très concrets de
faire prendre le virage vers des villes
vertes et plus vivable savez pendant le
confinement la pollution a baissé le
bruit a baissé c'est là aussi qu'on se
rend compte que quand ça repart eh bien
on ne souhaite pas que tout reparte
exactement comme avant bruno latour
disait c'est le moment si cette crise ne
permet pas de prendre un virage si on
choisit pas quelle activité faut
encourager et lesquels il faut réduire
et bien cette crise aura été gâché avec
le 28 juin le vote écologiste c'est le
vote pour le changement le passeport le
véritable passeport pour le changement
pour des villes vertes agréable et
vivable et oui parce que on voit surgir
des alliances et aussi d
des verts qui sont en bonne position
dans certaines communes on sent que les
relations sont encore compliquées avec
le parti le parti socialiste où il y a
des accords qui sont qui sont formulées
à rennes à nantes
et puis à paris évidemment et d'un autre
côté on voit des grosses difficultés
alors dans ma bonne communes de l'île
mais aussi à strasbourg concrètement est
ce que ça se passe mieux avec les
socialistes
est-ce que c'est comme on dit sur
facebook c'est compliqué mais je pense
que ça aussi un trait parce qu'il ya des
socialistes qui ont pris en compte la
mesure de l'écologie et je pense que
vous parliez de de rennes - les retours
que j'ai eu des discussions s'étaient
féconde
c'est à dire que non seulement des
discussions ont bien sûr sur gagne
l'organigramme le dispositif mais à
l'issue des discussions du premier tour
eh bien il ya un projet véritablement co
construit à partir des propositions
écolo et des propositions socialistes
pour la ville de rennes star que pour
les six ans à venir
eh bien ça a permis de construire
quelque chose de meilleur c'est heureux
est ce à dire que martine aubry par
exemple elle n'a pas pris en compte
l'écologie
martine aubry est une grande dame mais
pour l'école pour elle l'écologie c'est
la portion congrue
ça n'a aucun intérêt et donc quand
stéphane baly fait 25% quel candidat
écologiste ali 25%
vous pouvez pas balayer ça d'un revers
de main et à vrai dire si stéphane baly
avait accepté que ces voix ne compte pas
pour faciliter un accord ils auraient
quelque part trahir son engagement
devant les électeurs les électrices et
donc il ya des points durs notamment sur
l'urbanisme
aline et bien martine aubry a choisi de
faire cavalier seul et j'espère que
stéphane bas niveau le regretté d'une
question d'ego oui clairement je pense
est question d'ego question aussi de
génération parce que malheureusement
catherine trautmann à strasbourg a fait
exactement le même choix
malgré le fait d'avoir été distancé dans
les yeux par jeanne d'arc ayant elle a
voulu s'accrocher à la métropole qui
sont aux postes qu'ils sont des go et
c'est le choix de catherine trautmann
c'est actuellement un accord à
strasbourg est sûre nous nous jetons un
accord nous souhaitons nous souhaitons
remporter ces villes et les mettre sur
la voie de la transition
nous ne disons pas que nous allons le
faire seul donc pour ça il s'agit de
construire des coalitions
mais il faut qu'elles soient bien sûr
centré sur l'écologie en tout cas
qu'elle le prenne dignement en compte à
la hauteur des voix exprimées
lui au premier tour donc malheureusement
à strasbourg votaient trautmann c'est
voter à droite très clairement donc le
le choix des électeurs et des électrices
de gauche et des électrices et électeurs
écologistes
ces jeunes brillants et à lille il ya un
match il ya un match et il ya de vrais
projets qui s'affrontent continuer comme
avant depuis une vingtaine d'années avec
ses vrais l'apport des écologistes ou y
aller beaucoup plus franchement sur
l'écologie la justice sociale et la
démocratie c'est la gagne et falbalas
band bien sûr on joue on est déterminés
j'y serai le 21 pour soutenir la
mobilisation pour la protection de la
friche saint sauveur alors ça dérape
t'es pas grand chose à tout mot toute
votre audience à le lecteur du met ces
grands projets en effet au coeur de
l'oqre de la ville et je pense que ces
deux visions qui s'affrontent voyez vous
avez une friche une vieille guerre
industrielle voulait bétonné ou au
contraire vous voulez la rendre à la
population d'une ville extrêmement
minéral très pollué et proposer des
activités et surtout proposait de
sauvegarder ses terres naturelles
il nous reste peu de temps on va parler
du havre où là aussi la liste écologiste
n'a pas trouvé d'accord avec le candidat
communiste cette fois qui affronte
edouard philippe
est-ce que vous ne facilitait pas la
victoire du premier ministre mais je
regrette je regrette véritablement que
le coq le candidat n'est pas souhaiter
fusionner notre liste avait fait 8 %
j'ai pas je pense qu'il aurait été
logique dans ce cas là notre candidat
avait bien sûr proposé il peut pas se
mentir il avait proposé la fusion avec
les communistes qui ont choisi de faire
cavalier seul
c'est dommage alors fabien roussel qui
était sur ce plateau la semaine dernière
appelle à une campagne commune de la
part des partis de gauche contre le
premier ministre vous irez je serai
d'abord en soutien bien sûr où vous
comprenez au candidat écologiste a
lingua à besançon à strasbourg à tour à
toulouse à lille ça c'est la liste des
prochains déplacements et comment vous
expliquez que à la fois les socialistes
à lille
et à strasbourg que la haye les
communistes au havre pucé accord avec
les écologistes est ce que pour vous
n'êtes pas crédible sahnoun lui c'est
une question démocratie vous fait 20
pour représenter dignement vos
électrices et aux électeurs vous devez
être représenté à hauteur de ses vins
vous fait huit ans l'acceptent mais
simplement ça doit être accepté
également par la personne qui propose
une fusion or en l'espèce ces différents
candidats que vous citez considérer que
les 8% ou les 25% sur l'écologie ça va
c'était trop en fait est-ce que la
dépression est ce que ça ne présume pas
finalement dit un avenir assez compliqué
pour l'union de la gauche une mais nous
notre réflexion commune qui pourrait
aboutir à une candidature a au mieux à
la présidentielle l'union de la gauche
c'est au mieux un moyen c'est pas une
fin l'enjeu c'est quel projet l'enjeu
c'est de proposer une alternative
heureuse au pays par rapport à un duo
entre emmanuel macron mais marine le pen
qui abîme le pays et donc il faut
proposer une alternative heureuse nous
disons cela doit se construire sur
l'écologie la justice sociale la
démocratie toutes les personnes qui se
retrouvent dans ce triptyque si on les
bienvenus pour le construire
merci beaucoup de liens baillot maire
monsieur lamarre était avec nous ce
matin merci julien lécuyer demain votre
place ce sera lexsi corbières le député
la france a soumises de seine saint
denis et on passe ensuite au club des
territoires